what's uh so what's next oh you're
talking about yeah like I really did
something like Krishan curious what's
like what's next with the music [__]
like what's coming down the pipeline
besides season two of the TV show what's
what do you all got
huh what do you got coming in next songs
yeah a baby season two of the show
any uh any any other like we know he's
got a restaurant do you have any
entrepreneurial stuff going on on the
side that you wanna merch the merch
yeah is the merch out huh is the merch
out not yet coming soon
when's the next music dropping
I mean I guess you're the label right so
when she's dropping some new music
yeah I mean I usually let her decide you
know choose on which way she want to go
with it
and then I just put all those things
together so you're not it's safe to say
you're not passionate about music
it's not that just
or passionate about like
the dates right no you just gotta pick
one and
and say like how you want it to be
what about movies Krishan I feel like
you would be a great she's a good actor
I feel like you could be in some movies
she's a hell of an actor
boy I tell you Kev I feel like there's a
lot she's good right now there's a lot
she's stabbing the table with the knife
damn
really quiet
they say one good thing you turn into
something wrong with you no I'm serious
clapping way too hard over there you
stabbing the table a little too hard
over there oh man making me worry can I
hold that that's uh I'm not ready stop
playing with me
stay over there what is he doing what
would you guys say
like what's the last date y'all went on
that was like not
you know do you guys go on dates are we
are we hitting the [__] bowling alley
are we going to dinner like like what's
quality time with y'all two like
quality time
well Utah
you want to get that one I'm always
getting there why won't you answer any
other questions you don't answer all the
questions
um quality time yeah we go bowling I
like to bowl
uh that's not quality time we go eat you
do that with anybody well what's quality
time Krishan
okay
that's what she is
are you at least writing your name on
the table as you stab it because at
least then if someone's like yo what
happened to the table here I'd be like
just read what it says right and
Christian rock was here
um no but what's quality time with y'all
Christian what do y'all like y'all going
to uh goddamn dinner is it walks on the
beach
working out I don't know I'll probably
just at home for real at the crib you
guys live together yeah
nice
what is that what you get what's up with
you
oh look at you guys
see y'all get along bro
how long has has okay because obviously
what is happening right now
that's the [__] coloring book we're
gonna [__] end up with with a just a
carved up wooden table